uh it has to be topped up right until
the last minute because it can evaporate
you'll see those arms kind of
falling away just before launch in the
last couple of seconds
so up here in the sky booth in the
mission control center we have nasa's
rob navies and the european space
agency's loose fabric
they're standing by hi guys standing by
to take on the commentary when we get to
about 15 minutes to launch but right now
michelle all the boards are green we go
for launch back to you michelle
we'll be coming back to katie for the
final phases of the countdown in just a
little bit
so i'm an astronomer and this launch is
a huge deal for me i am personally
really really excited but why is this
such a big event for everyone
the webb telescope is nothing less than
humanity's next effort to move closer to
understanding
some of the biggest questions about the
origin of our universe
it is not just the origins of distant
stars and galaxies but it's the story of
us
you and me how we got here
and speaking of questions we'd like to
include yours in this historic event on
whatever platform you're watching our
coverage drop your questions with the
hashtag ask nasa later in the broadcast
we'll answer some of them live on air
it can't be said enough that this is a
mission for anyone who's ever looked up
at the night sky and wonder
people all over the world are sending in
their best wishes for the success of web
and let's look at some of them now
[Music]
james thread
[Music]
web
[Music]
[Music]
we're still on track for a launch at 7
20 a.m eastern u.s time
two days ago the rocket rolled out to
its launch pad in kuru
of course there's already been a lot of
activity at the launch site primary
fueling procedures were completed early
this morning preparing the giant ariane
5 rocket for flight
let's watch the scene for a moment
[Music]
do
[Music]
we know the world is watching today
humanity begins its next bold adventure
to extend ourselves out into the cosmos
this is something we do as a whole
planet all of us together
be fitting the global importance of this
initiative let's review some of the
basic facts about the observatory shared
by people all over the world who are
looking forward to the web mission
the entire world is looking forward to
the launch of the james webb space
telescope
let's hear more from a people around the
globe
about what makes webb a scientific and
technological marvel
proximo and principal observatorio
espacial para los astronomes
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
thousands of people all over the world
have worked for years to get us to
today's launch the core partners nasa
the european space agency and the
canadian space agency are the principal
players
but a vast core of engineers scientists
private companies and more have had a
hand in building this one-of-a-kind
scientific platform
without a doubt this is the most complex
spacecraft ever built with revolutionary
technologies daring mission goals and a
whole lot of personal passion and
commitment
we'll hear from our partners later in
the broadcast but first let's hear from
someone representing the science
community with a rare perspective about
space exploration
hello i'm isa astronaut matthias maurer
currently living and working on the
international space station iss i'm very
excited to follow the james webb space
telescope's launch with you all from
space even with the naked eye we
astronauts see that the stars are
credibly sharp and brilliant once we are
outside the earth's atmosphere james
webb space telescope will be the largest
and the most powerful telescope in space
yet and it was built to study the big
questions questions like where do we
come from how did galaxies form like our
milky way
how are stars and planets born like the
sun and the earth
might there even be life on other
planets
the james webb space telescope is a
joint project between nasa the european
and the canadian space agencies and by
tens of thousands of people with origins
in many countries it will be used by
scientists everywhere on earth
nasa goddard is the home of the webb
telescope with big sections designed and
built here but actual mission operations
take place here
this is the mission operations center or
mock at the space telescope science
institute in baltimore
after launch this facility will command
and control web for the duration of the
mission we'll be looking at the mock at
key moments throughout the broadcast and
this will become a familiar location for
viewers in the weeks ahead as the web
team begins to set up the telescope for
work in space
so as we move closer to launch we'll
actually keep a picture of the launch
facility right here on the screen but
for the next 10 minutes or so we're
going to talk about some of web's
principal science goals
if you've ever seen a telescope before
i'm certain it didn't look like this
of course the look of this particular
machine is a direct result of the
scientific questions it's been built to
pursue
so fortunately we've got an expert pair
of guests with me this morning to help
explain those science goals and much
more so i'm joined now on the set by
nasa's deputy project scientist for
exoplanet science nicole colon and also
uh with macaria macarena garcia marin
the instrument calibration scientist for
webb's miri instrument from the european
space agency so welcome to you both
thank you thank you so this is our
chance to kind of step back and talk
about the science goals of web you know
this is the part that really excites
astronomers like all of us
and um i know that uh there's unusual
things about being an infrared telescope
there are specific science schools
infrared answers so maybe you could
start us out nicole with uh you're an
expert on exoplanets how is the infrared
really important for your study
sure well with exoplanets we want to
study their atmospheres and as a
reminder exoplanets are planets that
orbit distant stars so we're looking for
very small signals when we study their
atmospheres and web is this giant
telescope that we're able to use to
collect these small signals and look for
infrared signatures chemical signatures
of
water and methane and carbon dioxide
those types of molecules in their
atmospheres and
why the infrared you know that's really
because
those signatures are the strongest in
the infrared we know
that they exist there and so that's why
we want to use web to look there it
seems an amazing idea so exoplanets
plants around other stars are light
years away from us tremendously distant
so how do we know if it's water methane
i mean how can we probe an atmosphere so
far away
well with webb there's a couple
different ways but one of the main ways
is actually using the transit technique
and this is an indirect method where we
actually detected the decrease in
starlight
that happens as a planet goes in front
of its star
but then imagine the planet has an
atmosphere well there's an additional
decrease in the starlight because the
atmosphere blocks some light from our
point of view and why it blocks the
light is because there's usually a
molecule or something in there like
water and methane like i mentioned that
is acting as an absorber and blocking
the light from our telescope in this
case web
so going from you know the relatively
nearby nearby stars and planets macarena
you're an expert on very distant things
distant galaxies so how does infrared
contribute to your field of study
so with web we're going to be able to
observe the very first galaxies in stuff
we're talking about three and a half
billion years ago so it's really
mind-blowing if you think about it and
why infrared well those galaxies emitted
their visible light
many many millions of years ago and that
light travels so results in time and at
the same time the universe expands so in
that process of travel and expansion the
light shifts from the visible to the
infrared and so we will be able to
actually observe those very
original primeval galaxies and not only
those but it will also allow us to
observe everything in between so we can
understand the evolution of our galaxies
from the first ones to the ones we see
today this is something kind of amazing
so our eyes interpret different energies
of light as different colors an infrared
light is a color that our eyes are not
sensitive to but like you said it's
actually just the space of the universe
stretching out the light and changing it
from visible light into infrared
exactly so how are these first galaxies
different from galaxies today
well when you look at the images we have
of the oldest galaxies we've seen they
look like fluffier and clumpier we know
they have a lot of star formation so
that they are actually that's a really
good signature to to measure them and
they
they are like little seeds that
afterwards they merged and and
together and evolved until the ones we
see today which are like spirals and
elliptical galaxies
so from you know the the near universe
to the far one of the things that
infrared is very good is seeing through
dust that's another huge advantage maybe
nicole could you sort of take us through
that story sure you know with dust
there's well first there's a lot of dust
in the universe and but
how stars and planets form in the first
place they are forming these very dense
clouds of gas and dust that come
together and it's very difficult to see
through them
with normal visible light and so the
infrared is actually able to see through
that almost like an x-ray you know sees
your bones um sees through our skin you
can use the telescope-like web to see
through the dust and see the inner stars
forming or see some newly formed planets
that are also very warm from having just
formed
and there's even a possibility of seeing
some of the the very first stars or at
least some evidence of the first stars
that might have existed could you tell
us a little bit about that macarena yeah
so the very first sisters they form
right around the time of the very first
galaxies even before that and so we'll
be able to measure them maybe not the
very first one but the first population
of the stars which is really interesting
because they were formed out of a very
pristine material and then from there
they evolved into
more of all the stars that created all
the elements we know today things like
gold platinum carbon everything us we're
from out of those original stars so it's
a really it's a really amazing adventure
to observe all these uh objects and
understand them better you know there's
so many wonders in the universe and one
of the things that i would never have
believed was real unless i'd seen it the
data with my own eyes is the trappist-1
system and that this is actually going
to be one of the targets for website
right tell us a little bit about travis
sure trappist-1 is like you said it's
going to be a target um there are seven
planets in the system
and they're all small around the size of
earth actually so it's also very compact
system so it's not just that there's a
lot of planets and that webb's going to
observe every single one of them but
it's the compact nature that's just
really fascinating because
the entire orbit of the planetary
systems like all seven planets they fit
inside
our orbit of mercury around the sun and
mercury is our closest planet to the sun
so imagine seven planets in there and
you know there's a lot going on but it's
very exciting because we'll get to learn
and do comparative science and see are
all these planets
do they have the same chemical
signatures in their atmosphere you know
do they all have same amount of water
carbon dioxide things like that well
thank you so much we'll be back to talk
to you more but thank you for joining me
thank you okay
so we'll be back in some more minutes to
uh to talk with them and remember that
we're taking your questions so use the
hashtag asknasa
web looks like nothing that's come
before because it's pursuing scientific
goals like none that have come before
it's taken years to prepare it for
flight and as you might imagine plants
of this scope and scale inevitably run
into unexpected challenges
along the way just like any of us it
encountered things like snow storms in
the east wildfires in california
hurricanes that deluged houston texas
and of course the global covid 19
pandemic which added its own profound
challenges to the whole team this story
really warrants a recap so check this
out
the webb space telescope presented many
engineering challenges but engineering
hasn't been the only obstacle the team
had to overcome
in 2011 an outbreak of tornadoes cut
electricity to the marshall space flight
center in alabama for nearly a week
while the team rushed to finish
cryogenic testing on the primary mirror
segments using power from diesel
generators
engineers had to endure a large snow
storm known locally as snowmageddon
while testing the integrated science
instrument module at the goddard space
flight center
and of course everyone has had to
contend with the global pandemic
one particularly memorable challenge was
working through hurricane harvey in 2017
this massive cyclone dumped 40 to 60
inches of rain across the houston area
over a four day period causing
catastrophic flooding and 125 billion
dollars of damage
all while the telescope was undergoing
cryogenic testing at nasa's johnson
space center
though the telescope remained safe
inside the test chamber
water leaked through the ceilings
people had to cover workstations and
plastic tarps
food was in short supply and a few team
members trapped by floodwaters had to be
rescued by boat
it was rough to say the least but the
team and the telescope survived the
storm despite winds and snow and endless
rain the team got it done and webb is
now ready for its final journey atop a
rocket into space
[Music]
while the webb telescope is a
technological marvel everything here
began with questions questions about how
the first stars and galaxies came to be
questions about whether planets around
other stars might have environments that
can sustain life
and of course the promise of discoveries
we can't even predict yet
a few days ago i had a chance to speak
with someone who's probably the best
person on earth to help us understand
what we know what we don't know and how
web will help fill in those gaps
dr john mather is a nobel prize winner
who measured the big bang with an
observatory built here at nasa goddard
john is webb senior project scientist
and we're so pleased to have you here
today john good to be here with you
michelle
so to start this incredible story of
webb let's start with something that's
deceptively simple gravity there's
something special about gravity gravity
is special gravity always pulls it's the
only force of nature that always pulls
so that's special and what makes that
special is that gravity although it's
very weak is very long range it can
reach across the universe and slow down
the expansion of the material that came
from the big bang turn it around pull it
back together turn it into galaxies and
stars and eventually planets and a place
we could live so that's what makes
gravity special among all the forces of
nature
and something so simple like just the
idea that it's always pulling together
that simplicity leads to wonderful
complexity doesn't it yes because it's
always pulling it's possible for
gravitational energy to be converted
into kinetic energy that's just
heat
and the universe becomes self-heating
which is not something other forces
could do all by themselves clouds of gas
can be
compressed by the gravity until they get
big enough and hot enough to light up
and have the nuclear reactions inside
that turn hydrogen and helium into the
chemical elements you see around you
here in the house here on the set so
carbon oxygen nitrogen everything we
have that we think of as ordinary came
from inside stars so we are stardust as
carl sagan told us but there wasn't any
stardust in the big bang so we need this
part of the story to be figured out how
did we come to be able to live here on
our little planet
when the universe started out without
all of these goody things
so you mentioned these planets around
other stars so we're almost sort of
going through all these amazing science
goals of the web what can what what can
web tell us about planets around other
stars well once in a while a planet goes
in front of the star and some of the
starlight goes through the atmosphere
the planet if it has an atmosphere on
its way to the telescope we will spread
out that light into a spectrum
or what you would call a rainbow and
we'll analyze it to see what are the
chemicals that are in that atmosphere so
we will be able to tell you
maybe that's the plan uh whether those
little planets that might be like earth
actually could have for instance water
in their atmosphere and maybe enough
water so there could be a liquid ocean
under that atmosphere one of the great
questions so we know they're planets now
we know when we should look uh we just
don't know what we're going to see
so i i after the web launches one of my
dreams i'm going to be standing outside
of my backyard and point to a star and
say there's a planet around that star
that we know has water vapor oxygen
perhaps methane carbon dioxide so what
is webb going to also do in the search
for life closer to home our own backyard
well here in our own solar system we
will be looking at everything from mars
on outwards to the farthest we can see
satellites comets asteroids and the
planets themselves and some of them are
really interesting and special because
we know they're
possible homes of life
what would make a thing a home of life
well if it's wet that's a good clue so
the satellite europa which orbits around
jupiter was discovered by galileo
himself
and we know now that it has an ocean
that's covered with ice
there's there are cracks in the ice
where water comes spitting out
we nasa are going to send a probe over
there to fly through those plumes we're
also going to point over there with the
web telescope to see what can see about
that atmosphere and those plumes of
water we'll be looking at titan which is
a satellite of saturn which is so big
that it has an atmosphere enough to fly
a helicopter and it is cold out there so
that
what they have what
is on the surface is solid ice
and over that are liquid hydrocarbons
which you would use for fuel here in
here in our home
but over there it's liquid rain lakes
and rivers and we will be looking at the
geology of that before we send the
helicopter out there
so you're on this amazing journey from
the very distant early universe all the
way to our own solar system but this has
also been a personal journey for you
you've been working on web since the
very beginning of the mission is that
correct i have since 95 we had our first
conversation
but people were even dreaming and
imagining
way before that what we needed and you
could tell even before that we launched
the hubble what were the possibilities
and we learned that we would need an
infrared telescope that could do things
that hubble could not do
well john i've been admired of yours for
many decades now and it's an honor to be
with you on this part of the mission so
thank you so much for joining us best of
luck on the launch and the mission ahead
and thank you for asking all these great
questions
the hubble space telescope delivered
profound insights about our place in the
cosmos but perhaps the biggest takeaway
from hubble is that we've only just
scratched the surface
hubble gave us the best ever views of
stars and planets forming inside vast
dark clouds of dust but as soon as we
had that data we were asking new
questions that needed better
measurements clearer images
hubble was also able to capture images
from galaxies so far away the light took
13 billion years to travel to us
these distant galaxies are just tiny
dots and hubble's images tantalizing
scientists with clues about how the
first galaxies form
in order to pursue a better
understanding about the earliest days of
the universe we needed to build a better
time machine and that's webb
so i'm going to be rejoined here by
nicole and macarena and this is our
chance to talk a bit about building that
better time machine what about the
technology of web so there's so many
aspects of web to start off with but but
maybe again going back to the theme of
infrared the design of this telescope is
so different because we had to use
infrared light heat light so tell us
about some of the challenges of you know
for example why does it have to be so
cool tell us about infrared light in the
design right well i think uh we've heard
already just how cool it has to be you
know it's around or below 50 kelvin and
that's
minus 370 degrees fahrenheit actually
below that is what it operates at and
that's very cold and the reason we need
it so cool is because we don't want the
telescope itself to detect itself
because there's there's several
instruments on board there's four
different instruments and you know
there's some moving parts and so you
need things to be cool
because you want to detect these faint
signatures from either an exoplanet
atmosphere or you know faint light from
the earliest stars and galaxies so you
just don't want to detect your own
telescope
macarena you are the instrument
calibration scientist for the coolest
instrument
so tell us a bit about myriad why it
needs to be so cold so maybe it's a
really unique instrument and it's a
great example of this collaboration we
have in this mission because it's half
european half u.s and so mary is the
only instrument on board that uses the
mid in front of the light and the
midified light is a bit
rather a bit cooler than the nearest red
light and so because of that meeting is
to be colder in order to detect that
very faint signal from high-received
galaxies or protoplanetary disks etc so
because of that it has it's the only
instrument on board that has a cryo
cooler so it is not only the passive
cooling from the sunshield it is active
cooling and it brings that and breaks it
down to about
minus 450 fahrenheit so it's really
extremely cold a few degrees above the
absolute zero
and we were talking about you don't want
the telescope to be so hot that it's
basically giving off its own signal its
own radiation and that leads us to why
it needs to be in space right so tell us
a bit about why do we need to launch
this thing into space to see these
wavelengths
well again it kind of goes back to
atmospheres because earth has an
atmosphere and there's water in earth's
atmosphere as one example i mean there's
a lot of other molecules but basically
in the infrared at the wavelengths that
we want to observe some of these stars
and and planets and galaxies
those wavelengths are actually where
earth's atmosphere is opaque so with
telescopes located on earth even
at higher mountains where they try to
get above the clouds or atmospheres
sometimes there's still residual
atmosphere that we're trying to look
through and peer through so
in order to see the full infrared
wavelength range at a very high
sensitivity as well we need to go to
space
absolutely so we talked a bit about some
of the power of techniques like
spectroscopy we've heard we've heard dr
john mather talk about it so let's go a
little bit more into the details of how
spectroscopy works and why it's so
powerful
oh sure yeah i can keep going you know
well with spectroscopy um
we heard so visible light again is kind
of it's a rainbow of colors that we
don't see naturally but if you use
something like a prism you can separate
out that light and see all the colors
from you know blue to red but then the
infrared is redder than the human eyes
can see
but you can still do the same technique
where you have uh spectroscopy
tools or instruments like webb has all
these spectroscopic tools so that we can
break up the infrared light and look at
certain colors if you will
so that we can see certain features that
we are looking for whether it's
the right wavelength where you know a
galaxy might be bright or where water is
absorbing in an atmosphere so macarena
mary has many different capabilities
in fact it has one that that i believe
is it's something different called
coronagraphy as well yes talk a bit
about all these ways that we're going to
detect you know different signatures
from planets tell us about chronography
it's an amazing technique but
essentially it simulates an eclipse so
we have a very bright star with planets
around for instance
usually when you take an image the stars
outshines the light of the planet so you
don't see them but with midi and with
other instrumentation as well you can
actually block the light of the star and
dim it and then you see the planets
around and it's really that technique
that's going to be
very much used and and to do like in
this image direct imaging of planets
well thank you so much we'll be back to
talk to you more with some social media
questions thank you very much thank you
nasa and its partners began developing
the web telescope years ago growing from
an initial inspiration to a design than
schematics and finally reality
what started as a big dream for studying
the origins of the universe required
best-in-class engineering expertise to
transform into something real
let's take a short look at the very long
story about the earliest days of the
james webb space telescope
before the hubble space telescope even
launched scientists were already
discussing what should come next
ideas for what was then called the next
generation space telescope evolved
throughout the 1990s and by the end of
the decade nasa had a preliminary plan
[Music]
construction of the james webb space
telescope began in 2004 beryllium was
mined to create the mirror segments
which technicians polished and coated in
a thin layer of gold
meanwhile engineers designed and built
new science instruments in the u.s
europe and canada
every step of the way there were reviews
and tests to make sure each part could
withstand the rigors of space flight
by the early 2010s the team began
bringing individual components together
at nasa's goddard space flight center in
greenbelt maryland
it was there that the mirrors and
instruments began to coalesce into the
grand machine we see today
we've said before that the james webb
space telescope is an incredibly
ambitious mission
big ambitions come with big challenges
and that's certainly been the story of
webb from the beginning the design of
this observatory has been a balance
between the boldest questions scientists
have dared to ask and the cutting edge
technology that our best engineers could
offer
the design for web evolved from earlier
ideas of what a telescope could be
another example of the delicate balance
between desire versus capability
to get a better understanding not only
the missions goals but also the
mechanical guts of the observatory
itself i recently got a chance to speak
with a pair of engineers who know the
anatomy of the web telescope better than
just about anyone
i'm here with keith parish a senior
engineer on the web mission and keith
you brought something to show us today
yes i did so
conceptually webb sunshield is actually
quite simple all we need is five
tennis court size pieces of this
material outstretched to protect the
telescope from the sun so what i have
here is an actual sample of that
material this is just kapton so light
yeah it's an industrial you can buy this
and on you know it's commonly used and
what we do is we buy it for web we seam
it all together in small pieces and uh
and then we actually coat it with
special coatings to give it the what we
call the thermal properties we need in
orbit so this one has a nice pink or
purplish kind of hue to it and the
reason it's purplish and hue this we use
this on the sun side and uh we actually
put a silicon material on this cap ton
and then we actually put a little bit of
a metal in it and what that metal does
is it gives us a nice electrical
conductivity we don't want any surface
charged
surface charging building up and the
other thing is this silicon coating
actually drops the temperature of this
layer so and also it's very durable and
can survive you know for many many years
in space and then this whole thing has
to unfold somehow where we could
actually see that behind us exactly
right so if you look at that animation
there unfolding there so it's actually s
folded up
uh almost like a like a fan we
we call it s-folding and uh once we get
it all folded up we secure it to a
structure by actually pinning it for
launch so you know a huge shout out to
our mechanical engineer and our entire
sunshield team because they've come up
with some really clever ways to secure
this for launch unfold it fold it and
then you know ultimately get it safely
deployed in orbit that's wonderful so
speaking of unfolding and all these pins
that need to release let's go over here
and talk to james cooper going to show
us what's going on there hi uh so i have
here an example of a non-explosive
actuator
uh we have 178 of these these are all
the pins we're talking about james webb
right 107 of the 178 are the membrane
release devices
and we use this type of actuator because
it it produces a very low shock when
it's released
and the animation shows conceptually how
it works we send an electrical signal
through
either one of our connectors we use both
but either one of them can cause the
release to happen it melts a small wire
inside
and then we have a spring that unwinds
and allows two halves of an of a split
nut to separate and then our pin
can get extracted and so in the case of
the mrds it's a spring-loaded pin that
pulls to release the folded membranes in
other places we would be bolting two
pieces of structure together and then
releasing them so we can deploy them and
the sun shield itself has 107 of these
107 mrds that all have to work every
single one every single one has to work
and 178 of this type of device in
various configurations around the entire
observatory right well if we go over
here we've got something sort of lovely
waiting for us a big gold hexagon so to
tell us what we're looking at a sort of
a model here of a mirror segment right a
full scale
single segment one of the 18 mirror
segments on james webb
the real ones would be machined out of a
single piece of beryllium to the exact
curvature we need
and then once we're deployed on orbit
each segment can be individually focused
to make
it act as a single perfect mirror now
that coating tell us about this gold
coating here yeah so this is uh you know
coated with a very thin layer of gold
it's only a few hundred atoms thick of
gold and and that gold is really good
because it gives us a reflective
property in the infrared and that's
really what web is is an infrared
telescope and we need that sun shield
exists to cool this entire telescope so
this mirror actually runs about minus
400 degrees fahrenheit on orbit if it if
it were warmer than that the infrared
energy
coming off of this that heat energy
would swamp our detector system and our
instrument so that entire sun shield
exists to cool all 18 of these down and
again this this gold coating is what
does helps with all that reflectivity to
make it perform even better well that's
wonderful so you put it all together and
we have a uh a smaller mock-up here the
sun shield the mirror tell us what we're
looking at here much much much smaller
so yeah this is our entire observatory
fully deployed on orbit and you can see
the sunshield here is is a large feature
you can see all five layers that i
talked about earlier and it's the
separation of those five layers which
lets heat energy escape out the space
before it eventually gets to this cold
layer again that entire telescope is
running minus 400 degrees fahrenheit and
the way we get it that cold is this side
is shaded uh the telescope is looking to
the deep universe which is near absolute
zero and then again this this layer here
we've got about a 500 degree temperature
drop so this telescope is also looking
at this layer here which is nice and
cold so that's what lets us you know
harness thermal physics to cool this
down to those really really cold
temperatures again you can see our booms
which are fully deployed and stretching
this out and then ultimately all folds
up and gets stowed into this structure
for launch
right so the membrane release devices
would be
along the back side of these structures
on the forward and the aft side
and we release them in
rows
so that we can sequentially start to
unfold the membrane once those pins are
pulled out of the way well that's
wonderful thank you so much for joining
us and best of luck on the launch i'm
very excited yeah thank you
okay let's get a live launch status
update from nasa commentator rob navies
at the launch site rob how are things in
peru
well thank you michelle and merry
christmas from the jupiter control
center here in kuru french guiana
you are looking live at an ariane 5
rocket on its launch pad
ready to send the james webb space
telescope on the initial phase of its
journey
the fueling of the ariane 5's first and
upper stages began before sunrise and in
the last few minutes mission controllers
here in kuru and at the telescope's
control center at the space telescope
science institute in baltimore conducted
polls with all positions reporting they
are go to proceed into the final phase
of the countdown
launch controllers have been monitoring
weather conditions throughout the night
keeping tabs on clouds and wind speeds
both at ground level and in the flight
path of the ariane 5 ensuring that all
of the precise commit criteria are
acceptable for launch
right now we have a green board no
issues as the countdown proceeds no
issues again being tracked by the flight
control team here in kuru
by the way our broadcast today is a
collaborative effort between nasa and
the european space agency
so that's it from now from the ariane 5
mission control here in kuru we'll be
back with you soon for now let's go back
to the goddard space flight center and
michelle fowler
thank you very much rob
so webb asks big science questions it
demonstrates astounding technology it
inspires and excites people to dream and
wonder
and the spark of inspiration is the
ignition of creativity kids all over the
world have a natural affinity for webb's
big pursuits
and now we have a collection of young
artists ready to showcase their work
hi everyone i'm kelly girardi and this
is delta v and we're kicking off the
unfold the universe challenge with nasa
and the james webb space telescope nasa
is hosting an unfold the universe art
challenge use your imagination to share
what you believe the web telescope will
find
i believe
that the web telescope will see
galaxies stars
planets
the moon
and don't forget
our star
the sun
[Music]
up in the sky
i'm
thanks greta good job this is
[Music]
hello my name is april i am
from romania
this is how i imagine space hello
everyone good morning this is the
drawing of distant galaxy that can be
seen by
james webb space telescope hi my name is
anastasia and this is
what i do what i think the telescope
will look like what the telescope will
see i drew the earth the sun
a new planet
black hole
and stars
so we've been fielding social media
questions for viewers all over the world
this morning and let's take a couple of
minutes to share some responses um
there's been a couple questions about
how long will it take for images to come
out and there's a lot of things that
need to happen before the images are
coming so macarena why don't you take us
through some of that yes so for the
first scientific
beautiful images to share with the
public that will take six months and the
reason is because it is so we launched
today
it takes a month to take to the orbit
place to the lagrange two point and then
we have a whole period of cooling down
the instruments aligning the mirrors and
making sure that all the instruments are
ready to decide so the whole process
takes
six months half a year and also all of
those 18 segments of mirrors something
needs to happen to get them all working
together too right exactly because
initially
you launch with 18 segments and they
work separately so you will take if you
observe one star you will get
18 little points so
there has to be a process where you take
images with nerca which is one of the
cameras on board
start moving the mirrors slightly to to
make them work as a single one and then
by the end of this iterative process you
go from 18 points to a very sharp
pristine single point source so all
mirrors act as a single one
so let's see we have a question from lv
coming in on twitter um will webb be
able to enhance detection of comets
asteroids or meteors that enter our
solar system so that seems we've got a
planetary person here sure
yeah well webb does have a special
observing mode where it's able to track
these rapidly moving objects because
compared to these distant stars and
galaxies asteroids and comets they move
pretty quickly and so webb will be able
to do this so that we can study uh
material that's outgassing from them and
learn more about what they're made of
so let's see there's there's so many
good questions we only have time for a
few more so one is from uh from
christian rodriguez on facebook uh how
long will it take james webb to reach
lagrange point two and you might also
just explain what is lirage point two
so it takes a month i think it's like
actually 29 days to get there and the la
rescue point is this very interesting
uh stable point so the gravitational
pull between the sun and the earth
create this point where it is stable and
you can
as you can see the
webcam orbit around the l2 point in a
very stable orbit only needs a little
bit of corrections once in a while
and it can always have the sun shield
protecting the telescope from the
radiation of the sun
in a year in a full year you can observe
any object in the sky and it's a
continuous observation
well thank you very much we'll hopefully
come back to a few more questions later
thank you so this is a big mission with
a cast of thousands to bring it to life
all over the world
as we get closer to launch let's take a
brief look at the main locations where
webb took shape on its journey to space
inside the massive high bay clean room
and nasa's goddard space flight center
engineers assembled the 18 gold covered
mirror segments into the back plane of
the telescope and integrated the four
science instruments contributed by
international partners to simulate the
harsh environment of launch they went
through vibration tests and acoustic
tests and to simulate a space
environment the instruments endured
cryogenic testing in a large thermal
vacuum chamber
but it wasn't large enough to hold both
the instruments and the mirrors so the
telescope boarded a plane to houston
texas to visit the only thermal vacuum
chamber in the world big enough to fit
the entire assembly
chamber a at the johnson space center
was originally built to test the apollo
spacecraft and half a century later it
provided a grueling 100-day test for the
webb telescope
[Music]
next the telescope traveled to northrop
grumman's facilities in redondo beach
california to meet up with its other
half the sun shield and spacecraft bus
fully assembled at last the entire
observatory went through yet more tests
many focused on making sure the
spacecraft could properly fold up for
launch and unfold in space
then in september 2021 webb caught a
ride on a specialized cargo ship and set
out on a 16-day voyage to the european
space agency's spaceport in kuru french
guiana according to its travel itinerary
that's webb's last port of call
on earth
once web gets into space we're going to
have some exciting things to tell you
about what happens next from its
extraordinary engineering to the
thrilling scientific adventure it's
about to enable us to undertake
but launch comes first and for that i'm
going to turn it over to katie haswell
our host at the launch site and one of
nasa's most recognizable voices launch
commentator rob navis
it's all yours katie
thanks very much indeed michelle well
it's all looking very good here at the
spaceport for a christmas day
launch operations running smoothly the
countdown ticking over nicely
all the systems are green and we are go
for launch you can see there the we're
looking at launch pad number three the
james webb space telescope inside the
very top of the rocket in first class
with its seat belt on
waiting patiently for lift off that's
scheduled in about 32 minutes time
i'm in the mission control center here
at the spaceport the nerve center of
operations we're about 10
kilometers from that pad and behind me
you can see
uh it's a laser focus here in the
control center with the mission control
centers all on console there as we get
closer to launch we call this uh the
fishbowl behind this uh protected glass
and up in their skybox here in mission
control are nasa's rov navies and the
european space agency's
loose fabrigate and they're standing by
to take over the commentary about 15
minutes
as we get closer to launch first of all
though let's check in on the countdown
and let's see how things are progressing
with stefan israel stefan is the ceo of
aryan space aryan space is the company
responsible for getting our telescope
into space today stefan
thanks for joining us no pressure good
morning
how are things looking so we are now 31
minutes before liftoff so far so good
iron five is ready
web is ready the range is ready and the
weather is going well that's that's good
to hear so what can we expect to see
what's going to happen yeah so in the 30
coming minutes we will make the final
operations 10 minutes before liftoff we
will have the final authorization of the
weather and seven minutes before liftoff
we will enter in the famous synchronized
sequence and uh i mean how's everyone
feeling i'm guessing everyone's
we launched for humanity this morning
from the guyana space center you know
what webb is about after well we will
never see the skies in quite the same
way it's an important project isn't it
forever it's a very special mission but
we have delivered already 111 times with
aryan this is a 112 iron 5 so we will
deliver this morning and everybody there
in the control center cool calm and
collected stefan thank you very much for
having taken time to step out of the
fishbowl for us so you can head back now
into the fishbowl and take up your
position stephan israel thank you very
much
indeed stefan of course heads up what we
call the flight desk which is the um
the
the authority that takes all the final
decisions in the event of unplanned
situations now we are in french guiana
we're on the northeastern coast of south
south america we're in amazonia it's hot
uh it can get a little bit sweaty
sometimes and there are lots and lots of
mosquitoes but somebody know who knows
it very very well is raphael chevrolet
raphael is a rocket science uh scientist
or a rocket expert at least from
arianespace thanks for joining us
raphael tell us a little bit more about
french guyana well french guna is a
french territory that borders brazil
it's located in the amazon rainforest 97
of the land is covered in trees so
that's why it's so green and beautiful
and you can totally imagine that the
wildlife there is absolutely incredible
this is actually one of the best
preserved habitat in the world and of
course it is
in the jungle and yet it is actually the
european space port so what makes this
location in south america so important
and so relevant well there are several
reasons for this first we are on the
coast it means that we can launch over
the sea from north to east without
having to fly over inhabited area so
this is very convenient to reach any
kind of orbit
there is no hurricane here big tropical
storm there is no earthquake but more
importantly we are very close to the
equator
so that we can benefit from what we call
the slingshot effect given by the
rotation of the earth so let me take
this globe basically here on the equator
we are all traveling at roughly 1 000
miles per hour that's very convenient
for of course we don't feel it if we
were on the poles that speed would be
very very close to zero it means that
when weight is right now on the launch
pad inside the fairing of the rn5 it's
already traveling
in the right direction and we can use
this extra boost to get us into space
that's also very convenient for web
because doing so it can save its fuel
and increase its operational life in
orbit at one and a half million
kilometers from here and that really is
important a million miles isn't it and
so there's a real proper slingshot
effect
and um
the facilities here are ultra high tech
and that's exactly what webb needs isn't
it yeah that's very convenient for web
it's also located in a nature reserve so
this is the perfect meeting between
nature and technology and people come
from all over the world to work here but
one thing that's been very important for
webb is
cleanliness because you know that one
spec of dust could alter the vision of
the observatory in space that's why we
have been extremely careful in keeping a
pristine environment in all our
facilities from rams arrival in french
vienna to sealing it inside the rocket
so let's talk a little bit now about the
web space telescope i really don't think
you need me to tell you that it is the
product of a feat of human ingenuity and
you don't get to make a telescope as
complex as the james webb telescope and
as remarkable without tremendous amount
of collaboration and the james webb
space telescope is indeed the product of
partnership between three space agencies
who came together to create it
nasa the european space agency and also
the canadian space agency so here to
talk about that now is greg robinson
from nasa greg thank you very much for
coming to the floor out of the fishbowl
as well for us and we're talking serious
teamwork here aren't we uh yes katie uh
we've benefited from an amazing
partnership with the canadian space
agency and the european space agency
over the life of the development we've
had more than ten thousand people
actually touch webb
29 states in the u.s and 14 countries
across the globe
and not to mention the the amazing
industrial base across the globe that
have benefited here
in order to do bold missions like this
it takes lots of resources and lots of
expertise so we maximize everyone's
expertise
and how did this bold mission
get onto an ariane 5 european launcher
so as part of the partnership the
canadian space agency contributed
science instruments and they're
incredibly important for this mission
and so did esa
science instruments and the amazing
ariane 5 that we will see take us on
this journey and put us in the right
direction to get to lagrange point too
and we're looking forward to that it's a
tremendous atmosphere here isn't it in
the in the mission control center
there's a real buzz here today i wonder
how you must be feeling greg i mean it's
got to be a very very emotional time
knowing that your telescope is sitting
there on top of the rocket getting
closer to launch
it's certainly amazing i often talk
about the butterflies and people keep
asking me have they started have they
started and yes they're starting and
when we get to about
uh 20 minutes out
they will start flying a lot
so well excitement is just amazing the
excitement is building and of course
everyone very cool calm and collected
thank you greg robson you can take your
position back in the fishbowl now
because i know you've got a lot of work
to do in there greg robinson thank you
very much indeed for joining us
um so the ariane 5 launch
vehicle is the heaviest lifter in the
ariane 5 fam in the ariane family of
launchers and rafael she has got an
incredible track record hasn't she of
success yeah this is a very reliable and
successful successful rocket uh webb is
going to be the 112th ariane 5 to be
launched and the first the very first
aria and the iron one took off exactly
42 years ago yesterday this was on
christmas eve 1979 good symbol yeah and
hopefully we're going to get a good
christmas present today as well and i
mean the rocket is also you don't get to
build a rocket like this without
collaboration either do you of course
just like web actually in fact 12
different countries have been
participating in the development of the
rn5 with aryan group now being the
industrial prime
and we have a scale model
right next to you raphael why don't you
talk us through it the rocket is made of
sections and we often call those stages
which is what you might hear during the
commentary exactly so first you have the
two boosters solid boosters that are
located on each side of the rocket they
will provide the main thrust in order to
literally push the rocket against the
gravity of the earth then you have these
big tanks that form the
main cryogenic stage with the main
engine vulcan at the bottom and then you
have the web telescope right at the top
inside the fairing it is right there on
the launch pad and together they are put
on top of the third stage a cryogenic
stage and it is this upper stage that is
going to place webb into orbit and what
about the engines what are we going to
see at liftoff at liftoff we first see
the main virgin engine
ignite first we do this because we want
to check it's prop it's working properly
before we switch on the solid boosters
seven seconds later
once it's done there is no turning back
the rocket is going to lift off and so
yeah that's a very uh
don't be surprised don't be surprised if
you don't see the rocket lifting off for
seven seconds that's time for the rocket
to actually warm up before soaring into
the sky
so once we light the touch paper you can
count to seven
uh before it actually lifts off now one
of the advantages of the ariane 5
vehicle is that it can be modified and
that's exactly what we've done for
today's launch we've had to make some
changes for it to be able to host the
web satellite and joining me to talk
about that is somebody who the right
person for the job indeed because he was
in charge of those uh changes daniel de
sombra from the european space agency
thanks for joining us daniel what did
you have to do
first we need to recall that web will be
the largest payload to be ever
accommodated on our own i5
it fully occupies the volume of the
fairing with gaps as small as 10
centimeters for a diameter of 5 meter it
is a reason why we had to develop a
specific
integration procedure to ensure that
there is no contact with them
after separation
uh during separation sorry uh the
advancing system of uh
of the launcher has been improved in
order to balance as much as possible the
inside and the outside pressure
of the fairing and this is to to uh
due to
the fear of depressors depressurization
shock which could damage the delicate
layers of uh website essential
after separation
uh the
due to the fact that
web
some
equipment of web are very sensitive to
sun exposure
the role control of the launcher will be
tuned in order to make sure that web is
always oriented only one face to to the
sun
and in addition to avoiding your spot
the launcher will be
crea will create some oscillating
movements like a bbq mode to avoid any
over overheating
and after after web separation
uh there will be a specific end-of-life
maneuver
to to be applied on the upper stage in
order to put it on the liberation orbit
around the sun in order to avoid
collision in the in the long term thank
you very much indeed daniel so we'll
hopefully see the uh upper stage rocking
in space not quite all the way around
like the familiar barbecue but a
slightly different
movement listen gentlemen thank you very
much indeed for being with us today i
know that you're busy you've got jobs to
do inside the fishbowl so i'm going to
send you right back there now and very
best wishes for the launch thank you
thank you
our telescope has a long journey ahead
of it it's got to travel a million miles
to its destination in space it's working
zone where it's going to start telling
us all about our universe it's already
started
that journey
because it's travelled to the launch pad
from los angeles
after final tests were concluded in los
angeles
webb was packed
into a special container
and transported along the la
405 freeway which had to be closed
because it's so big
it traveled on a special ship
a lot of
spacecraft will come to the french
guiana launch site by plane but webb was
too big for that so it had to travel by
ship and it went through the panama
canal
up through the locks
and it took 16 days
to get to the port
in kuru
where it was unloaded
and traveled to the spaceport that's not
the real ariane 5 that's a model
just outside the jupiter control center
actually
it was unpacked
very carefully in the facilities that
raphael was talking about
and then fueling started and of course
the teams had to wear special suits
because that's
a dangerous job and then it was placed
all the way
on top
of the ariane 5 rocket
it was encapsulated inside the fairing
and sealed
and then it was rolled out to the launch
pad two days ago
from the vehicle assembly building to
the pad along very special rails
very very slowly through the amazon
rainforest
it was raining at the time
and that was two days ago and here we
are now
17
minutes and 46 seconds to launch and
counting all systems are go
here at the european spaceport in french
guyana we have three control centers on
the job today we have
the mission control center here we also
have the launch control center which is
about a mile from the pad and then we
also have the
telescope control center mission control
in baltimore in the us and that's where
the operational teams are standing by to
take over the telescope operations
once it's released from the mothership
that will be
about 27 minutes after launch
and they'll be controlling the web
telescope for the rest of its life
very important job
the james webb space telescope is a
truly
remarkable observatory
people have been working on it for
over two decades some people have been
working on it for their whole
professional lives
uh thomas zabrooken is the head of
science at nasa and
he's joining me now just to talk about
it's thomas
i mean or dr z as uh we can also call
you
the day has come
all these decades all this time all
these people working on the telescope
and here we are
16 minutes and counting to launch
it's a big day huh oh i'm so amazed
right we have this telescope on top of
this rocket a telescope that
10 000 plus people have worked on in
many ways and together with that
telescope all the hopes and dreams of
those individuals and also tens of
thousands of scientists some of them not
even born that will benefit from these
data are there with them waiting for
these last minutes of countdown for a
journey to space i'm guessing people are
feeling a combination of emotional
excitement
what's going through people's minds do
you think oh i think there's a
tremendous sense of accomplishment
whenever you're on top of a rocket many
things went really really well there's
tremendous pride there's always a little
bit of anxiety we know launching is hard
we have one of the absolute best teams
in the world working on this right now
so i'm confident in that we're super
excited i mean i just an amazing day
today and what are you most excited
about dr z
well i'm a scientist for me besides the
technology that really is a marvel i
mean it's really the best we can do what
i'm thinking about is really looking at
the universe in new light we have never
seen the universe how web will show it
to us and can you just imagine going
back in time and a half billion years it
boggles your mind even as a professional
astrophysicist
kind of just think about all the new
things we're going to learn about our
most beautiful universe
dr z thank you very very much for
joining us and i want to wish you and
all the teams everybody the very best
for for today's launch thank you
so yes indeed go web so we are now 14
minutes and 30 seconds to launch
we're getting really close now
everything's going well all systems are
green for launch and i'm going to
hand you over now to
nasa's rob naviers in the sky box
alongside
the european space agency's luce
fabriquette who are going to take on the
commentary from here on in over to you
guys rob
well thank you katie merry christmas to
our worldwide audience from our
broadcast booth high atop the jupiter
control center here in peru
joining me today for this historic
launch my colleague luce fabregat the
head of infrastructure and value chain
for the european space agency lewis good
morning
great to be with you great to be with
you today
very pleased to be here with you and all
of you watching us for this very special
event
well at this hour countdown clocks are
ticking backward we are at t minus 13
minutes 32 seconds and counting
out on the launch pad everything is in
great shape don't let those clouds fool
you we are go for launch the latest
weather briefing just completed
indicated that all weather parameters
are green we have a green board here in
the control center and everything has
gone extremely smoothly in the countdown
about nine minutes ago a major milestone
passed as the james webb space telescope
began the process and completed the
process of receiving commands to
transition from external power to
internal battery power following the
latest in the series of those weather
briefings
web will remain on internal battery
power until its singular solar array
unfurls about 30 minutes after launch
earlier telescope controllers reported
good environmental readings from sensors
inside the fairing encapsulating the
telescope atop the upper stage of the
ariane 5 rocket and loose as we enter
the most critical phase of the countdown
can you outline
some of the upcoming critical activities
as we head into the phase called
synchronized sequence yes rob we are now
reaching the end of this uh 11 hour
sequence that we call the chronology and
that started yesterday evening all
systems here
have been prepared for the final launch
operations and at the time being it's
quite it's it's rather quiet now inside
the launch table and also inside the
launcher
we were told a few minutes ago by the
launch control center here that the
launcher fleets and electric systems are
ready for the final automated sequence
they are on old now waiting for the last
weather report at minus 10 minutes
after this weather report
three minutes later we will have the
beginning of this famous synchronized
sequence when all systems will be made
ready for the liftoff
this sequence will first be ran by the
ground calculator
and then the onboard computer will take
the lead step by step and the launch
vehicle will be made autonomous from the
ground system
you know that we have two tanks in each
cryogenic stage upper stage and main
stage
all four tanks are of course
thermally insulated from the hot
environment where we have here in french
guyana
however these liquid propellants are at
very low temperature and because of that
slightly evaporate
and to ensure
they are perfectly loaded at liftoff
their final loading and topping up
will last up to four minutes before the
launch so that will be the beginning of
the synchronized sequence run by the
ground calculators
then we will have
on the free side
the end of the the topping the final
loading and the topping up of the of the
different tanks and on the electric side
we will have the onboard computer
getting prepared for the launch also and
it will be
uploaded with the h0 with the h0 time
the time for the for the liftoff
which is today at nine at the beginning
of the window 9 20 local time
7 20 eastern time
and loose so we're coming up on that
final uh weather report uh we expect all
systems to remain green
we'll be going down to the fishbowl to
confirm that just a moment or two from
now
it's a 27-minute ride to orbit
from liftoff until the time that the
web observatory is separated from the
upper stage of the ariane 5 rocket
several minutes later the commands will
be given to unfurl its solar array
followed by the confirmation from the
telescope controllers in baltimore that
we are power positive meaning that
electrical current is flowing through
that solar array
with us today inside the so-called
fishbowl seated with mission controllers
on the floor of the control room is
rafael chevrier of ariane spas raphael
how's everything looking what's being
discussed down there
hi rob well so far so good we just
received the last weather forecast it's
all green for the hdro that is forecast
right now what we checked was altitude
winds wind in the vicinity of the launch
pad and risk of lightning so right now
uh it's it's a relief because the the
weather was a bit tough in the last
couple of days but right now everybody
is very focused on the next steps the
start of the synchronized sequence at
seven minutes before liftoff last
operations that lose described earlier
before webb and the iron 5 are going to
lift off and soar into the sky
thanks raphael we'll be back with you
and luce here shortly we now have
confirmation from baltimore that james
webb is on internal power
amidst all of this activity we cannot
forget that it is christmas day
53 years ago the astronauts of apollo 8
completed their 10th and final orbit of
the moon after reading from the book of
genesis on christmas eve to billions of
people watching with rap detention back
on our planet the astronauts then headed
for home following their spacecraft's
trans-earth injection burn today more
than a half century later we're just
minutes away from another genesis
the genesis of new era of discovery the
launch of the james webb space telescope
is at hand
we're just 38 seconds away from entering
the critical synchronized sequence
you're going to be hearing uh
all the critical calls from the ddo the
range operations manager
who is jean-luc voyer here in the launch
in the mission control center there he
is
he will be calling the start of
synchronized sequence all of the
critical countdown milestones and we
will be listening very intently for his
calls let's standby
set minute
and with that we've entered the period
of synchronized sequence
you heard loose fabricate just a moment
or two ago
uh explain some of the critical
activities uh the first one coming up
just a few seconds from now which will
be the topping off of the main stage
tanks
the
first or core stage was loaded earlier
this morning with 175 tons of propellant
150 tons of liquid
oxygen
and 25 tons of liquid hydrogen the upper
stage loaded with 15 tons of propellant
that will be the workhorse for a 16
minute burn to lift james webb to its
final orbit uh at separation some 27
minutes and seven seconds after launch
james webb will be at an altitude of
about 864 statute miles to put that into
perspective
some
520 miles higher than the hubble space
telescope and more than 600 miles higher
than the international space station web
at that point will be traveling about 21
000 miles an hour as it heads out to a
highly elliptical halo-like racetrack
orbit some one million miles from earth
to begin its scientific observations
in a little more than one minute from
now we will see the four tanks
pressurized at the flight level for the
last tests before the ignition of the
vulcan engine
and in parallel the electric system are
also set in flight configurations
onboard computer the electrical power as
for the telescope it will switch from
ground to internal power one minute
before the launch one minute and five
seconds before the launch
and we are going to see minus six
seconds
at minus six seconds we will see the
disconnection of the upper stage this
big cryo technic arms you can see on
this on this picture
then three seconds before the h0 the
inertial platform that will give all the
information about where it is to the
launcher will be released
and at h0
the seven second sequence to ignite the
vulcan engine of the main start stage
will start
that will take seven seconds a little
less than seven seconds where the engine
will start up to its flight regime
once the computer has checked that the
vulcan engine is running normally
and you will see at that point of flame
going stable at the outlet of the nozzle
and at that point the onboard computer
will ignite the two boosters that will
enable to move the
770 tons of ariane and webb
coming up on the t-minus four minute
mark right now uh just a couple of
milestones real quick at the one minute
five second mark into the flight uh
ariane 5 will go through the period of
maximum dynamic pressure max-q as it's
known
that will be the period of maximum
aerodynamic forces on the rocket itself
the solid rocket boosters which will
provide about 90 percent of the initial
thrust off the launch pad
will shut down and separate at the
two-minute 21 second mark into the
flight followed a minute and five
seconds after that by fairing jettison
that will expose the james webb space
telescope to uh the environment of
flight for the first time the main stage
separation or the first stage separation
comes at the t minus at the eight minute
47 second mark into the flight and that
will be about a 16 minute burn of that
upper stage engine it will cut off
at about 24 minutes 51 seconds into the
flight and then we'll go into a coast
phase of about two and a half minutes to
allow any oscillations to dampen out
provide the most pristine environment
for the james webb telescope before
observatory separation
we're coming up on the two minute 50
second mark into the flight again you're
going to be hearing critical calls down
the stretch here from the ddo or the
range operations manager jean luc voyer
the weather is go we have a green board
no issues being worked
nasa officials including greg robinson
on the right uh carefully uh watching
the telemetry
looking intently at the final couple of
minutes of the countdown lives have been
spent in the preparation of the james
webb space telescope that is about to
fly
and bear chris romero is on his side on
the left of the screen
from iron space
and that is the ddo the range operations
manager jean-luc voyeur as we have hit
the two-minute mark in the countdown
the flight will be in two phases you
will see the first part of the flight
during the solid rocket boosters phase
that will be the atmospheric part of the
flight the atmospheric flight
and the trajectory will be driven by a
very
to reduce the aerodynamic loads and we
will have a very different
exo atmospheric flight after that
and and you were watching a number of
people vips and invited guests moving
out to the observation platform that is
right next to the jupiter control center
as we stand by for the one-minute call
from jean-luc voyeur
magazine
thumbs up from jean luc voyeur all
systems are go we're inside a minute now
t minus 50 seconds and counting
as you heard earlier
the vulcan 2 engine will ignite
turbo pumps will come up to flight speed
for 7 seconds and the command will be
issued to ignite the solid rocket
boosters the james webb space telescope
will be on its way
t minus 30 seconds and counting
standing by for terminal count
top
rainforest to the edge of time itself
james webb begins a voyage back to the
birth of the universe
punching a hole through the clouds 20
seconds into the flight good pitch
program reported
[Music]
vehicle performance is nominal
[Music]
the ariane 5 rocket continues uh
to fly uphill in nominal fashion
[Music]
the rumble of the powerful ariana time
now being felt here in the control
center
3d animation
[Music]
we can hear the noise and feel the
vibrations here you're right rob yeah
impressive
13 kilometers in altitude seven
kilometers down range
traveling uh
about uh
0.6 kilometers per second
the trajectory reported to be nominal by
jean-luc voyeur the range operations
manager
you can see at the bottom of your screen
the yellow line is the trajectory plot
perfectly overlaid over the green line
which was the pre-launch trajectory
one minute 41 seconds into the flight
about 40 seconds away from
shutdown of the solid rocket boosters
[Applause]
coming up on the two-minute mark into
the flight
when it detects the threshold on
acceleration that this not the
deceleration but
less acceleration
everything is okay everything is normal
two minutes 15 seconds into the flight
when the computer detects this threshold
it will separate
we have confirmation of solid rocket
booster separation from jean-luc voyeur
this coming at an altitude of 44 miles
the ariane 5 and james webb traveling
almost 5 000 miles an hour
we have about one minute five seconds to
go before faring jettison that'll be the
next critical milestone
the fairing is there to avoid a
satellite being exposed to high
temperatures and also high air flows and
as soon as the launcher
leaves the atmosphere as is now the case
the satellite does not need anymore to
be protected and
webb does not need any more treatment
so each kilogram
being very important for the performance
of the launch we are going to eject this
no more useful fairing
and let's go down to the floor in the
jupiter control center to rafael
chevrier of arianespas raphael so far so
good
hi rob so far so good everything is
nominal as we say when attitude and
trajectory of the rn5 is going perfectly
well as you can see also on the yellow
on the screen we had the confirmation of
the separation of the two side boosters
and now off the fairing meaning that we
have crossed the limits of the
atmosphere so everything is going
to normal and the ddo just said that all
parameters are going perfectly perfectly
smoothly so let's continue the mission
and raphael this is a view from the
upper stage camera called the vicky cam
looking back at the james webb space
telescope this is on about a 20-second
delay or so because the way the imagery
is processed uh here in the control room
there's your telescope ready to unfurl
uh its wings basically and begin its uh
journey to the lagrange point the l2
point about a million miles away from
earth
trajectory is nominal the report from
jean-luc voyeur
the liftoff time confirmed here in the
mission control center at 12 20
greenwich mean time 9 20 a.m
time 7 20 a.m eastern time
the ariane 5 and james webb 181
kilometers in altitude
400
50 kilometers down range from the launch
site here in carew
flight control is very smooth
time and it's 12 seconds into the flight
we have about three and a half minutes
to go
in main stage or first stage performance
and again you can see at the bottom of
your screen the yellow plot line
overlaid over the green line
meaning we are right on course right
down the pike and a perfect trajectory
so far for the ariane 5 rock
all telemetry data are now received by
the galileo tracking station which is cl
which is close to here where we are
in kuru
it will track
the
in brazil
essentially
as you can see on the map in the middle
of the ocean and the two last stations
in africa
libreville and malindi one on the east
coast the other one on the west coast
and the one on the west coast malindi
you can see that the satellite will be
the telescope will be separated moreover
more or less over this malindi station
and this malini station will also
acquire the telemetry data from the
telescope
you can see both are green galio and
dental on this animation it means
they are expected to receive the data
and it was confirmed right now by the
launch
operations manager
of brazil
and just confirming now that telemetry
is being processed through the brazilian
tracking station the telescope is also
processing telemetry through the
tracking and data relay satellite system
as it moves further and further out into
deep space all of the telescopes
telemetry and its imagery ultimately
will be processed through the deep space
network in goldstone california we
passed the seven minute mark into the
flight a perfect ride
so far on the ariane 5.
we have about
one and a half minutes to go in the
first stage performance
once uh the main stage engine is
commanded to cut off
it will be jettisoned and just a few
seconds after that the upper stage
engine will will ignite and it will be
the workhorse for a 16-minute burn that
will put james webb into its preliminary
orbit
about 11 minutes from now telescope
controllers at the space telescope
science institute will be sending
commands to prepare james webb for the
initial uh series of commissioning
activities
that will lead to to the deployment of
its solar brakes
and the initiation of generation of
electrical power for the telescope
about 30 seconds away from main engine
cut-off
nominal trajectory continues to be the
watchword for the day from the range
operations manager jean-luc voyeur
as we stand by for main engine shutdown
and separation
and we have main stage shutdown and
separation confirmed here in the mission
control center and the ignition of that
and raphael chevrier down uh in the
fishbowl uh
so far so good yes rob we have the
confirmation of the separation of the
main stage and the ignition adjectives
the trajectory is perfectly nominal this
is a very important moment for us
because it's always
a challenge to switch on a cryogenic
engine
in space condition and we are now
at
220 kilometers of altitude
speed is a bit more than seven
kilometers per second
as we enter now the second stage of the
second phase of the flight the upper
state is going to power for about
for about 16 minutes to place web on its
transfer orbit and right now everything
is again nominal as the ddo just said
and a short time from now uh the
so-called sawtooth maneuver uh will get
underway that again uh like rocking a
baby in a cradle this will be a maneuver
to keep websites protected from
overheating loose exactly rob like a
baby in a cradle
you can see here web attached on top of
iron 5 upper stage
with a very specific configuration of
course it will be different during its
lifetime but for the time being it's
it's it's
sun shield is folded and not yet
in the observatory
a number of the population
studies have been performed by the
mission teams in europe in the u.s on
the temp thermal conditioning inside the
telescope and the way the rays of the
sun would propagate and interact with
sensitive equipment inside the telescope
the maintain this thermal conditioning
is really key before separating this
this telescope and in particular we know
that one face of the telescope cannot
face the sun that's why
the and to produce these right thermal
conditions inside the web specific role
law
has been designed what we call the
sawtooth approach and if you are if you
are watching carefully to these images
you can share this animation you can see
that the upper stage is going 30 degrees
on one side
then 30 degrees on the other side going
back and forth this way to
to maintain this perfect thermal
conditioning for the for the telescope
it's uh worthwhile noting that uh after
acceleration
from the upper stage
of the ariane 5 rocket which continues
to perform in excellent fashion at
coming up on the 12 minute mark into the
flight
the telescope controllers uh will be
taking the baton if you will from the
mission controllers here in kuru uh the
first steps will be the opening of fuel
valves a pair of fuel valves to start
flowing fuel to webb's onboard thrusters
they then will power on the valve drive
electronics those are powered on in
preparation to control and fire those
thrusters when required
webb's solar array is scheduled to be
deployed at approximately the
33 minute mark into the flight
once it is locked in place we'll get the
call uh that electricity is flowing
through the array that call will come
from the mission operations manager carl
starr who is at the space telescope
science institute at johns hopkins in
baltimore
seated right behind him in that control
room is elysia star a pair of stars
helping to guide james webb on its
discovery of the stars alicia starr is
the lead uh engineer for launch and
ascent events
uh once
deployed
then a three out of the four hold downs
for the aft deployed radiator will be
released to prevent binding due to the
cooldown of the telescope's composite
structure
the contamination control heaters will
be enabled to protect instrument optics
on web from any water ice condensation
as they cool down
the actuator drive unit will be powered
on this particular mechanism helps with
heater control
preventing water ice can condensation
later to be used to position each of the
mirrors segments
all six reaction wheels and the wheel
drive electronics will be powered on for
web and that will be the precursor to
the attitude control system using those
reaction wheels to maintain the proper
orientation with the sun as opposed to
using on-board thrusters
of course fuel
in those thrusters very valuable it's a
limited commodity for the lifetime of
james webb's
observations of the universe
we're 13 minutes 55 seconds
jean-luc
voyeur the range operations manager
continues to report a nominal
performance for james webb
and again loose fabricate from the
european space agency uh how is this
trajectory being uh carefully and
methodically adjusted uh to provide the
correct parameters uh in the final
stages of ascent yes rob as you can see
on this plot
the the altitude is slightly going down
it's perfectly normal the launch vehicle
is really on the on the line where it
should be
this decrease of its altitude slight
decrease of its altitude
will allow the launcher to benefit and
the upper stage to benefit the gravity
effect and to increase its velocity
until it reaches a thermal threshold
it's about to reach it or even already
reached it now and it will go up and now
it will go up and up
up to the separation of the web
telescope
it will separate the web telescope on a
highly elliptic orbit but still around
the earth the satellite the telescope
will be released inserted on the object
around the earth with an aputure very
high apogee above
normal
trajectory nominal as reported by
jean-luc voyeur you see him in that view
185 kilometers in altitude uh some 4 500
kilometers downrange from the launch
site here in kuru moving at more than
eight kilometers per second
right on the plot right on the
trajectory everything looking great
we are about uh
nine minutes away from the completion of
upper stage ignition it's shut down and
then about a two and a half minutes
before webb will separate observatory
separation will be called out you'll be
hearing those calls and the initial
calls from carl star the mission
operations manager at the space
telescope science institute at johns
hopkins through solar array deploy and
the declaration of a power positive
spacecraft uh you know james webb of
course will be traveling well beyond the
moon uh to a distance of about a million
miles away from earth settling into a
highly elliptical halo like
its astronomical observations
and again as we mentioned earlier at the
time of observatory separation webb will
be at an altitude of approximately 864
miles statute miles traveling some 21
000 miles
an hour
we're about eight minutes
the stage has performed as planned
no issues reported uh the launch
occurring at 12 20 greenwich mean time 9
20 kuru time 7 20 a.m eastern time on
this christmas day
the velocity you just mentioned is very
important rob the velocity you just
mentioned at separation of the telescope
is very important it will be slightly
below okay give it in a kilometer per
second but it will be slightly below 10
kilometer per second because it's
important that the satellite the
telescope is not inserted on an escape
orbit it will be placed on a terrestrial
orbit so that there will be time for the
last one
operations on the and the commissioning
of the telescope and that will be in
fact the upper stage that will leave
this orbit and goes toward an escape
liberation orbit
and of course even though we're still in
powered flight the trajectory the
acceleration the speed at which james
webb is going towards its preliminary
orbit
all modeled in advanced uh in advance
and carefully choreographed to maintain
as a quiescent an atmosphere and
environment around the telescope
for its ultimate separation from the
upper stage of the ariane 5 rocket which
is about six and a half minutes from now
eighteen and a half minutes into the
flight
it's very quiet now here in the uh
control center here in keru
nasa officials european space agency
officials
officials
all watching uh telemetry very carefully
and as the upper stage continues to burn
nominally and sheds fuel
the acceleration uphill for the james
webb space telescope continues to
increase as we approach the 20 minute
mark into the flight
again upper stage cutoff is scheduled at
24 minute 51 second mark into the flight
about five and a half minutes from now
after the cutoff of this main engine
as you say the rob we will have a short
ballistic phase a short costing phase
that will uh
when when the upper stage will rely
fully on its at what we call the
attitude and role control system and it
will
adjust its its attitude
so that during this so small ballistic
phase all the requirements from the
telescope are fully
met and that adds to separation when
when there will be the separation
the conditions will be very smooth and
as requested for the telescope
today's countdown was as flawless as you
can imagine
the weather was perfect uh all the way
through the early morning hours
uh through the fueling process of the
vehicle the weather's been a bit dicey
here in kuru over the past few days but
everything fell together on this
christmas day
to send a new present to the world's
astronomer
20 minutes 40 seconds into the fight
all parameters nominal as reported by
jean-luc voyeur the range operations
manager
four minutes of powered flight remaining
so
the telemetry of the launch vehicle is
acquired for the timing by the
libreville
tracking station on the western coast
flight control is
nominal the trajectory is
fully normal fully as expected as you
can see on the on the plot with the red
with the yellow plot over the green one
that is the expected one
22 minutes into the flight
less than three minutes of powered
flight remaining
smooth flight control
and again as we've mentioned before
everything nominal reported by the range
operations manager as we've mentioned
before
for the james webb space telescope to
put it at the proper position in the sky
so that it can escape from the earth
basically head beyond the moon towards
its final orbit uh for its commissioning
activities that will be the dominant
feature of uh all of the operations from
the space telescope science institute
over the course of the next several
weeks
and the launch operations manager
announced the acquisition
by uh by by lindim bide
by the malindi station
as expected
for the last
for the end of the flight and the last
part of the upper stage flight and the
separation of the telescope
james webb is about four minutes away
from separating from the upper stage
and again at that point uh
it will be on its own
and again those milestones that we
discussed a bit earlier in the broadcast
will begin to
be followed carefully by the telescope
controllers
at the mission operations
center the mock as it's called at the
space telescope science institute
one minute of powered flight remaining
the upper stage continues to function
perfectly it's been a smooth ride for
the james webb space telescope
that upper stage was loaded pre-flight
uh this morning with 15 tons of
propellant for this long 16 minute burn
now about 30 seconds away from upper
stage cut off
and we're standing by for upper stage
shutdown and uh the cutoff of the upper
stage engine
thanks
the extinction of the the shutoff of the
cutoff of the engine was confirmed
exactly as expected
with the
exactly
expected altitude and speed and velocity
so now we have
we have entered
the coasting phase the ballistic phase
that will last for a little more than
two minutes
and the telescope controllers uh in
baltimore uh confirming that all of the
function
uh parameters for the james webb space
telescope have been loaded on board the
telescope
we are expecting uh web separation at
the 27 minute seven second mark here
into the flight
just over a minute from now
springs will gently push web away from
the upper stage of the ariane 5.
as it moves further and further away
from the upper stage uh they'll be what
uh
we refer to as a collision avoidance
maneuver
yes yes rob exactly the springs already
will give
some distancing of course between the
two objects between the telescope and
the upper stage and then the upper stage
will leave the trajectory of the
telescope and makes a special maneuver
to pass the telescope and heads towards
a liberation orbit and leaves the
telescope
on its on its orbit
without any risk of collision and
without any risk of pollution towards
the telescope
and we're about 17 seconds away from web
separation
separation web space telescope go web
you do have confirmation of observatory
separation
the james webb space telescope amidst
applause here in the mission control
center
now taking its first steps in pursuit of
cosmological discovery
it was a perfect ride to orbit
and all of the separation sequence
events are running in good fashion
according to the telescope controllers
and there is the view from the upper
stage camera on the ariane 5 looking at
the james webb space telescope as it
moves uh
gently away
from its launch vehicle
[Applause]
fantastic pictures of this telescope go
web
yes go away
ironically enough as we marvel on this
view from the upper stage camera this
will be humanity's last view of the
james webb space telescope as it moves
to its work place about a million miles
away from earth yes you're right rob
impressive fantastic pictures yeah now
we'll be hearing uh shortly from the
mission operations manager at the space
telescope science institute
uh carl starr
who will be uh calling out the
procedures that will lead to the
deployment of webb's solar array
and down in the fishbowl uh where there
is jubilation let's go to raphael
chevrier of arianespas
and before we do that uh raphael uh a
bit earlier than planned but there is
the solar array having been deployed
james webb now uh has its array out as
we stand by for confirmation that it is
power positive
hey rob
[Applause]
that's
[Music]
and there it is there's your critical
call james webb not only has legs but it
has power
as it uh begins its journey and the
commissioning activities to follow and
with that let's go down to the floor uh
in the fishbowl and rafael chevrier of
arianespas
this is it we have witnessed and the
confirmation that rn5 have safely
delivered the wave into space the upper
stage is now being placed on a safe
escape orbit around this set but
honestly i've got to tell you that these
images are absolutely incredible and
well it may be the end of the mission
for in space but it's only the beginning
of the journey for a web it's now on its
way to the lagrange point
congratulations to all the team involved
in the flight really there is no words
to describe the emotion that is
happening right now in the fishbowl so
all i can say is good luck web and bring
us
incredible data from the deep universe
at that point our statements will
continue
well raphael uh congratulations on a
perfect ride to orbit uh from the ariane
5 out of peru here today a view here in
the space telescope science institute
their work just beginning on a new era
of scientific observations
loose fabricate
it was a smooth ride to orbit everything
went by the book almost like a
simulation without any problems and we
thank you for all of your insight
throughout the course of the day
thanks to europe and really a great
achievement i have many faces and names
now coming up to my mind and really you
can be proud of what what was achieved
on both
sides of the atlantic ocean
thanks a lot to you
tremendous jubilation here in the uh
control center you're looking at
jean-luc voyeur the range operations
manager
quite a christmas present for the
world's astronomers as the james webb
space telescope begins its life
heading towards deep space
with that uh we're going to go back to
the floor now to uh katie haswell katie
we did our thing it's up to you now
oh my goodness i just can't tell you
it's such utter jubilation here on the
floor in the jupiter control
center everybody's
[Music]
jumping up clapping whooping with joy
people hugging and i have to say i
ha my throat was caught as i saw that
the glimpse of
sunshine um on web solar panels as as we
watched it heading out into space on its
journey to its working zone it's going
to take about six months before we start
getting
um our deep space observations from
where of course the teams have got a
huge amount to do
before we get to that and our best
wishes with all those teams in baltimore
i want to get some reaction right now
everybody is talking and hugging each
other because they're feeling so excited
and i totally understand that let's
start though by going over to the nasa
administrator
bill nelson
okay
okay
administrator bill nelson right now
looking at these jubilant scenes here in
the mission control center in kuru
the european spaceport
in south america there are the teams the
mission controllers have
done a fantastic job it was an utterly
flawless launch
from
the european spaceport here on the
equator
in the amazon rainforest
hoping to go over now to nasa
administrator
bill nelson
to get some reaction from him
all stations seven and a half minutes
give or take until the sequence
continues with our
adir release part one and our tcs
configurations
[Music]
feeling the
jw6 can pick
foreign
[Music]
buddies
[Music]
[Music]
okay the range operations manager has
been calling out the milestones
throughout the flight today
and the esa teams
responsible for
so much fabulous work great teamwork
here to get the web
telescope into space and web is now
heading out on its journey
on its own with the mission controllers
the telescope mission controllers in